le 4 juillet 2012 le journal le monde
titre que les physiciens ont découvert
le boson de higgs avec 99,9 1999 pour
100 de certitude du jour au lendemain
les publications s'enchaînent avec
toutes sortes de médias avec des
annonces similaires
et pourtant très peu sinon personne ne
se plaint qu'il s'agit là d'une sorte de
techno ou du moins la publication du
cern ne dis pas qu'ils ont une certitude
de 99,9 1999 pour cent oui parce que la
vraisemblance des données n'est pas la
crédence de la théorie alors je n'ai
actuellement pas ça pour critiquer les
journalistes du monde
l'erreur dont on parle ici n'est pas une
erreur que commettent seulement des
ignares incompétent pas du tout
confondre la paix va lui c'est à dire en
gros le chiffre 85,9 1999 pour cent et
la certitude qu'on a en une confusion
suite à une étude par p value est une
erreur extrêmement commune
que ce soit chez les et éthicien les
scientifiques ou les mathématiciens par
exemple à titre personnel je peux vous
garantir qu'au moment où je suis devenu
docteur en mathématiques appliquées
ce qui est quand même ultra proche des
statistiques et alors qu'il y avait des
probabilités à tout va dans ma thèse est
que j'avais alors eu déjà l'occasion
d'enseigner un cours de statistiques
je peux vous garantir qu'à ce moment là
j'avais une compréhension très très
bancale de cette fameuse paix value et
de ce que ça signifie que d'avoir un
résultat statistiquement significatif ne
pas comprendre la paix value ce n'est
absolument pas un signe de stupidité
c'est juste que dans tous les cursus de
la maternelle au bac +8 la paix value
n'est quasiment pas enseigner et même
quand elle est enseignée aller parfois
enseignée par des ignares incompétent et
pourtant il s'agit d'un objet au coeur
de très nombreuses études scientifiques
c'est souvent cette paix va lui qui
détermine la conclusion que les
scientifiques tirent auront et si leur
article sera acceptée pour publication
ou non je dirais même que la paix va lui
est peut-être la plus grande révolution
de l'histoire de la méthode scientifique
et donc des sciences elle a permis à
tout un tas de sciences de la physique à
la biologie en passant par la chimie
l'épidémiologie et la psychologie de
drastiquement gagner en rigueur en
fiabilité et en validité pour 20 ans
comprendre la méthode capic les
scientifiques d'aujourd'hui est le degré
de validité de leurs coûts
fusion il faut absolument comprendre la
paix value or si vous n'avez pas pris le
temps de vraiment méditer la paix va lui
il y a malheureusement un fort risque
que vous la comprenez de travers et que
vous fassiez un contresens non seulement
vis-à-vis de la paix value ne peut être
bien aussi vis-à-vis de la méthode des
scientifiques en tous cas ce constat
semble commencer à sérieusement irriter
les statisticiens
certains comme john ioannidis baline
johnson tom siegfried ou reggina nous au
ont critiqué ouvertement la paix valu à
partir de 2005
et petit à petit les critiques
individuelles se sont transformé en
critique collective via une annonce par
exemple de l'association américaine de
statistiques ou via une publication co
signée par 800 chercheurs dans nature
il ya quelques mois aujourd'hui donc on
va essayer de clarifier la plus grande
confusion des sciences on va essayer
d'expliquer ce que la paix va lui est
vraiment pour comprendre la paix va lui
il est utile de faire un pas en arrière
et de parler avant cela de la méthode
scientifique décrite par le philosophe
karl popper en 1934
agacé par certaines théories qu'ils
considèrent ce dossier fiq hopper
introduit un critère de démarcation
entre les sciences et les patients ce
qu'on a aussi tendance appelée les
pseudosciences et popper remarque alors
que de nombreuses solutions auxquelles
ils pensent ont la propriété de ne pas
être réfutable c'est à dire qu il ne
semble pas possible de concevoir une
expérience d'où les résultats pourraient
permettre de rejeter la théorie pseudo
scientifique
voilà qui amène popper à introduire le
critère de réfutabilité pour qu'une
théorie appartiennent au domaine des
sciences selon popper il doit exister
une expérience dont les résultats sont
susceptibles de rejeter la théorie dès
lors selon paupert les sciences
consisterait essentiellement à réfuter
des théories qui sont potentiellement
réfutable c'est ainsi qu'on entend
parfois dire qu'en sciences ou ne prouve
pas les théories on les rejette la
science en tout cas les sciences
expérimentales serait ainsi avant tout
un processus d'élimination de théorie ce
principe de sciences par réputation a
depuis envahi les sciences il est ainsi
devenu standard pour un scientifique de
commencer une étude par l'énonciation
d'une théorie a réfuté cette théorie ou
hypothèses
je ne suis pas trop la différence ici
est souvent appelée hypothèse nul
elle est souvent noté à 0 mais pour
rester conforme avec les notations des
épisodes précédents je vais l'appeler
tpour théorie à tester ainsi bien
souvent un scientifique commence par
énoncé t puis il va collecter des
données d et il va ensuite se demander
si les données des suffisent a rejeté la
théorie était alors de prime abord on
pourrait se dire qu'il suffit que les
données des soit incompatible avec la
théorie t pour rejeter la théorie t
cependant en pratique il faut bien tenir
compte du fait que les données des sons
les résultats de plein de perturbations
statistiques difficilement contrôlable
comme les erreurs de mesure où les aléas
d'un échantillonnage pour déterminer
quand rejeté la théorie t autour des
années 1920 et donc en fait avant popper
le statisticien ronald fischer proposa
de rejeter tecan les données étaient
hautement improbable dans un monde où tu
es est vrai autrement dit la question
que fisher propose de se poser est la
suivante
admettons temporairement t les données
des sons tels raisonnable soute et où
sont-elles si improbable selon tes qu'il
est donc déraisonnable d'admettre t
lorsque l'étude de statistique conclu
que les données des sont hautement
improbable selon la théorie t fischer
propose alors de rejeter t10 de façon
équivalente
fischer propose la réfutation des
théories qui prédisent très mal les
données collectées des c'est pour
formaliser ce principe que fisher
introduit la paix value dont l'idée donc
la paix value est la vraisemblance des
données d en supposant la théorie tes
vrais alors en fait ça ça pose un petit
problème technique qui vient du fait que
si des est un nombre à six chiffres
alors toute valeur exacte 2d est en fait
peu probable selon teva typiquement
davantage prédire que des a de bonnes
chances d'être entre disons moins 1 et 1
mettez va aussi souvent ajouté que des
ce ne sera probablement pas exactement
0,135 1531 plus ou moins 1 000 000 1
en fait bien souvent tout donner dès est
hautement improbable
pour contourner cette difficulté
purement technique fischer note que la
distribution des données d va souvent
ressemblé à une espèce de cours
en cloche et du coup l'idée de fisher
c'est que la donne ait des pourra être
considéré compatible avec la théorie t6
des est au milieu de la courbe en cloche
prédite par t al'inverse qu'on pourra
rejeter la théorie t si les données des
se trouve très à gauche ou très à droite
dans ce que l'on appelle souvent la
queue de distribution pour formaliser ce
principe
fischer propose d'associer à tout donner
dès l'ensemble des rondes des données
plus extrême que des autrement dit si la
théorie t prédit une courbe en cloche
centré sur zéro décidée est égale à 1,4
alors des rondes sera l'ensemble des
données à droite 2d et parfois certaines
analyses inclut aussi l'autre côté de la
courbe c'est à dire les bois un gauche
que moins 1,4 en tout cas pour
aujourd'hui je vous propose d'étudier ce
second cas
fischer propose alors de considérer que
la donne et des et hautement improbable
si la probabilité des valeurs plus
extrême que des en supposant tes vrais
est très faible c'est cette probabilité
7 vraisemblance des données plus
incompatibles avec tes que la donne ait
observé ça chantait que l'on appelle
souvent la paix va lui et selon fischer
quand cette paix va lui est très faible
typiquement si elle est inférieure à 5%
ouah 1% ou en physique des particules on
utilise souvent quelque chose qui est à
peu près 0,0000 1%
si la paix value est inférieure à ce
seuil alors on peut rejeter la théorie t
selon fischer donc l'invraisemblance des
données suffit à rejeter la crédence de
la théorie dès lors on dit que les
résultats sont statistiquement
significatifs un résultat
statistiquement significatif c'est donc
un rejet d'une théorie t par une paix
value inférieur un slideshow n'est alors
la définition de la paix va lui en tant
que vraisemblance des données plus
incompatibles avec tes que les données
observées dès en supposant tes vrais a
de quoi faire quelques noeuds au cerveau
et oui j'ai même envie de dire que si ça
ne vous fait pas des noeuds au cerveau
c'est que vous ne comprenez peut-être
pas par exemple dans le cas du boson de
higgs
plutôt que de dire que les physiciens
ont 99 9999% de certitudes on l'a
découverte du boson 2
ce qui encore une fois est très fort il
faudrait dire que si l'on suppose
l'absence du boson de higgs alors la
vraisemblance des données plus
incompatibles avec l'absence du boson de
higgs que les données observées par le
cern est inférieure à 0,00 0 01 % et
rajouter que si l'on applique la méthode
de fisher avec un seuil à 0,00 0 0 1%
alors il nous faut rejeter l'absence de
boson de x sauf que tout ça c'est
compliqué à expliquer du coup les
scientifiques et souvent les
statisticiens et les journalistes ont
tendance à davantage dire que
l'existence du boson de higgs a été
prouvé de manière statistiquement
significative et ça cette expression là
elle fait grimacer certains
statisticiens notamment qu'à un résultat
statistiquement significatif n'est pas
nécessairement un résultat
statistiquement bouleversant dans la
mesure où il permet de rejeter t mais il
pourrait très bien coller parfaitement
avec une théorie des primes très proche
de tes n'y reviendra mais spoiler alors
que l'idée de statistiquement
significatif c'est très problématique
ceci dit pour un bail vient la paix va
lui reste une quantité très pertinente à
connaître puisque c'est une espèce de
vraisemblance des données et que la
vraisemblance des données fait partie de
la formule 2 bis en fait
qu'historiquement l'introduction de la
paix valliot par fisher a vraiment été
une révolution formidable dans
l'histoire des sciences et en
particulier de la méthode scientifique
c'est peut-être même la plus grande
avancée de l'histoire des sciences et je
trouve ça dommage qu'elle ne soit pas
aussi célébré que disons la mécanique
newtonienne autrement dit si vous n'avez
jamais méditer le rôle de l'ape évalue
alors vous sous-estimez très
probablement son rôle crucial dans la
validité des études scientifiques
cependant l inverse si vous utilisez au
quotidien la paix value sans avoir
longuement réfléchi à sa validité
épistémologique alors à en croire les
statisticiens qui en parle vous
surestimez très probablement
l'importance de la paix valliot en
particulier pour un bien il est très
important d'également insisté sur le
fait que la vraisemblance des données
selon une théorie ne nous dit pas tout
de la crédence de la théorie ce n'est
qu'un composant de la forme de baisses
parmi d'autres et du coup la
vraisemblance des données n'est pas la
crédence la théorie alors vu que la
formulation originale de la paix va lieu
n'est pas franchement intuitive on peut
se demander s'il n'y aurait pas une
la prestation équivalente de la paix
value qu'ils le soient davantage
eh bien il se trouve que oui en
particulier le seuil de la paix value
permet d'anticiper le taux de faux
positifs ou plus précisément la
probabilité de rejet d'une théorie tes
vrais on reprend fixons une autorité et
supposons que la théorie t est vrai
j'insiste dessus car le reste du
raisonnement s'effondre cité est en fait
fausse donc supposons tes vrais alors
t'es fais une prédiction concernant les
données des a observé disons que tu es
prédit une courbe en cloche maintenant
fixe aussi un seuil disons 1% en fait
fixer le seuil revient à identifier une
valeur des seuils tels que la
probabilité de donner des plus extrêmes
que des série est égale à 1 % et on peut
alors remarqué qu'une donnée dès rouge
et or à la théorie tu es si et seulement
si sont des rondes associés représente
une probabilité inférieure à 1% ce qui
arrivera si et seulement si des et plus
extrême que des seuils
autrement dit une donnée dès conduira
rejet de thé si et seulement si des et
plus extrême que des seuils
or par définition de des seuils en
supposant tes vrais la probabilité d'une
donnée des plus extrêmes que des seuils
est égale au seuil c'est à dire à 1%
ainsi ça chanter vrai la probabilité
d'avoir une donnée dès qui rejette t
avec un seuil à 1 % est égale 1 1 %
voilà ce qu'on peut appeler le théorème
fondamental de la paix valliot il dit
que si tu es est vrai alors le seuil de
la paix value est égale à la probabilité
de rejeter t à tort le seuil de la paix
value est la probabilité ça chanter vrai
de rejeter t en particulier si la
science ne s'amusait attester que des
théories vrai avec un seuil de 1% alors
1% des conclusions des études
scientifiques serait erroné voilà une
interprétation correcte de la paix
valliot cependant cette interprétation
n'est pas franchement applicable en
pratique
oui parce que si on savait que la
science ne testait que des théories vrai
alors on n'aurait pas besoin de tester
ces théories ou pourrait tout simplement
les accepter en pratique la science tu
est également souvent des théories
fausses en la paix value n'offrent
aucune garantie de rejet de théories
fausses ni de garantie sur la non
réfutation de théories fausses
de plus cette interprétation concerne
les conclusions des études scientifiques
or en pratique parce que le nombre
des études scientifiques est devenu
faramineux il est illusoire d'espérer
toutes les lire en pratique il ya
nécessairement une sélection de
certaines études scientifiques qui
conduit naturellement un biais de
sélection
pire vu le prestige associé à la
publication scientifique
il ya même un fort bien dit de
publication qui va typiquement favoriser
les annonces contre intuitive et
spectaculaire mais dès lors la
proportion de publications scientifiques
et rooney n'a aucune raison d'être
proche du seuil de la paix valu au
contraire comme on le verra dans de
prochaines vidéos de nombreux
statisticiens affirme que le taux de
faux positifs dans les publications
scientifiques serait quelque part entre
25 % et 90 % en fonction des différentes
disciplines et il est même très facile
d'imaginer des contextes où la paix
value est très bien appliqué mais où
100% des résultats publiés sont faux
même avec un seuil à 0,00 0,00 0 0 1%
j'insiste encore dessus la paix value
concerne la probabilité d'une conclusion
sachant la théorie vrai et ça en fait ça
ne nous dit pas grand chose de la
probabilité de la théorie sachant
qu'elle a été rejetée
tout ça parce que la vraisemblance des
données n'est pas la crédence de la
théorie autant dire que non ce n'est pas
parce qu'un résultat publié l'a été avec
un seuil de paix valliot à 1% que je lui
attribue une probabilité de 99% d'être
correct j'insiste encore une fois dessus
la vraie simple ans des données n'est
pas la crédence de la théorie
l'adf on a parlé des tests randomisés
contrôlés en double aveugle et pardoxe
leur marque en fait ce n'est pas tout à
fait une expérience toutes choses égales
par ailleurs puisque finalement on
traite pas du tout les mêmes individus
et en fait ça a pesé pas de métaphysique
de faire la chose toutes choses égales
par ailleurs
en fait ce qu'il faudra davantage dire
ce serait toute espérance égales par
ailleurs face à la randomisation peut
garantir sa fête le but de l'expérience
randomisés contrôlés en double aveugle
et davantage d'avoir des conclusions
tout distribution de probabilités a
priori sur les sujets égales par
ailleurs
et quand je dis à priori la sépare a
priori essence patience et a priori ou
sens avant l'intervention que l'on
cherche à tester
james ellman fait la remarque qu'on
pourra aller plus loin et au lieu
d'avoir un double aveugle on pourra
avoir une expérience en triple aveugle
oui parce que lorsqu'il ya une
expérience en w est légèrement il va
voir quand même
cain qui va essayer de suivre superviser
un peu ce qui se passe et pour qu'il
vérifie que tout se passe bien il va
quand même
et quand même utile qui sache un peu ce
qui se passe dans l'étude en particulier
si tel individu a reçu le traitement
qu'on cherche à tester ou non et ça en
fait ça peut potentiellement poser des
problèmes puisque cet observateur de
l'expérience s'il observe que quelque
chose se passe dans très très mal il
peut intervenir et du coup changé
les conclusions du test randomisée et du
coup certains ont proposé d'avoir une
expérience en triple aveugle ou vraiment
même si un observateur ne pouvait pas
savoir ce qui se passe dans le test
cependant là ça pose du coût des
problèmes d'éthique puisque plus
personne ne surveille ce qui se passe et
si ça trouve le traitement et les talent
musical a des conséquences très très
très néfaste à ce moment là il semble
vraiment désirable d'un point de vue
éthique de se permettre de stopper
l'expérience à mi-chemin reparlera
d'ailleurs des arrêts prématurés dans la
prochaine vidéo
enfin florian blanchet critique l'image
avec laquelle j'ai commencé l'épisode
précédent qui ébranle l'union inspiré de
wikipédia et qui présente la méthode
scientifique au singulier comme si tous
les scientifiques
appliquer cette méthode scientifique on
va être faut bien voir que c'est
absolument pas la méthode que applique
les scientifiques en pratique
en un sens cette image correspond plus à
côté normatif des sciences c'est à dire
qu'elle cherche à décrire des méthodes
que devra appliquer scientifique qui est
en fait assez distinctes de la méthode
des scientifiques c'est-à-dire la
méthode qu'à piquer scientifique en
pratique qui correspondra du coup à une
approche descriptive de la méthode
scientifique
alors il y aurait énormément plus de
choses à dire j'avais l'impression
d'être déjà suffisamment critique du
schéma en instruction de la vidéo
précédente
pour être un peu plus clair je suis en
fait extrêmement critique de cette image
on sait absolument pas ce que
j'utiliserai pour décrire ni la méthode
que devra appliquer scientifique ni la
méthode qu'applique vraiment les
scientifiques
le truc c'est que je vois souvent des
scientifiques dire que la méthode qu'a
piquant pratiques et scientifiques et
imparfaite et que tout se passerait
mieux si elle est scientifique appliquer
la méthode qu'il devra appliquer en
faisant souvent appel à ce genre de
schéma pour dire que si la science ne
fonctionne pas aussi bien que ce qu'elle
pourrait fonctionner c'est parce que les
scientifiques ne suivent pas la proche
normatif qui est décrite par ce genre de
schéma et à chaque fois j'ai envie de
rétorquer à ça en fait non c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça on va s'y
appliquer exactement ce schéma à l'aller
or je parierais centraux flipper que les
sciences se porterait en fait beaucoup
moins bien parce qu'en fait il ya
beaucoup de choses que ce schéma de
décrire absolument pas ce schéma est une
simplification extrême de beaucoup de
processus beaucoup plus subtil qui se
passe au niveau de la méthode
scientifique dont notamment par exemple
l'accumulation des connaissances qui est
vraiment un aspect ultra important de la
méthode des scientifiques en pratique et
qui me semble également importante de la
méthode que devrait appliquer des
scientifiques
bref il y aurait énormément plus de
choses à dire mais je voulais pas me
faire critiquer dans tous les sens en
présentant un truc trop compliqué du
coup j'ai commencé par le truc qui
semblait à peu près consensuel chez pas
mal de vulgarisateur en tout cas de la
méthode scientifique est en tout cas un
truc qui est présenté par wikipédia même
si je n'y adhère pas franchement elle
espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode et
que vous retiendrez que la paix va lui
c'est super important
mais qu a prévalu également très
imparfaite et que si on applique à la
lettre les choses se passent pas très
bien on va insister davantage sur ce
second aspect qui me semble très
sous-estimées notamment par la
communauté scientifique est en fait j'ai
tellement de choses à dire sur la paix
venue qu'en fait cela pendant les deux
prochains épisodes
on va donner une liste d'arguments pour
laquelle la paix value est en fête est
extrêmement problématique et qu'il est
temps de mettre en avant - d'autres
indicateurs des propriétés statistique
des données qui sont collectés si vous
avez aimé réaliser un conseil le lac est
le commentaire a le parfum ça vous
abonner pour le punk et le futur épisode
merci au team ford et j'espère qu'il
serait là la prochaine fois la tvas le
revenons aux résultats collectifs que
marine emilie et toi avez obtenu quatre
faces gagnante sur 60 lancé plutôt que
de me casser la tête à définir une zone
où oscar est blanchi et une zone aux
oscars est jugé coupable je vais me
poser la question suivante si le dos car
n'est pas pipé quelles sont mes chances
d'obtenir un résultat aussi suspect ou
encore plus suspect que celui obtenu la
réponse qu'on appelle paix valeur est la
somme des minuscules probabilité pour
les résultats 0 à 4 ce qui donne une
chance sur un million réalise bien
albert ce que cp valeurs nous dit si le
d'eidos carnet pas pipé marine emilie et
wav ya une chance sur un million
d'arriver à un résultat au moins aussi
suspect que celui obtenu
et pourtant c'est arrivé
[Musique]